yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet
visit expressvpn.com
we're back andrew the labor day
edition of yang speaks we've always been
here
if you listen you know we we didn't go
anywhere but yeah
we're we're back and and this
time it's to talk about all of the stuff
that's been going on the election
2020 uh 2020 is just the year that keeps
on giving
shitty things so hopefully so much has
happened
since our last our last conversation was
like four weeks ago three or four weeks
ago
so you've got both conventions which you
spoke at
you've got you crushed this republican
on cnn
uh we had two horror kills to be clear i
did not speak at both conventions
sorry you spoke at a convention uh
we were left off the card that was last
conversation i think we had
um the 2020 races tightening we had
double hurricanes new orleans
our boy chadwick bozeman passed away um
that was a shocker um
jacob blake um was shot brutally
um seven times leading to more protests
uh i was on vacation for a little bit
which i don't get to do very often so
that was nice you hung out with dave
chappelle
which was kind of cool um
i did do that thank you dave happy
bladed or not i mean i was actually
there on his birthday so but now his
birthday's past so if
if you see him you could say happy
belated birthday
um and then now it's fall man can you
believe
andrew that we've been quarantined since
march
can you believe yeah that blew my mind i
i said it's september the other day and
i thought wow that's six months
uh and one of the things that i
believed zack is that this summer was
pretty awful
uh for many many people but it was still
summer in the sense that you could still
just walk
outside and you know you would look
around and say yeah maybe things aren't
all bad because no the sun is shining
and the rest of it
i've been not excited about this fall
and i've got kids who are school age and
it does not look like their schools are
operating in a normal way um
and so yeah i feel for folks but it's
it's labor day we're back at it
we also have this very messed up sports
schedule because a lot of people i know
associate labor day with
a return to certain sports as well
uh which i mean the nfl is happening uh
i'm pumped for them no
and like i i i i confess i'm like i'm
scratching my head as to whether the nfl
is going to
be able to operate the entire season
because the nba took
massive uh building
precautions and the bubble on the rest
of it like i would feel confident the
nfl
was playing if all the teams were
together in some bubble somewhere
right but but if you have teams that are
practicing and traveling around
uh even though the stadiums i think will
be half empty
you know i'd be concerned and football
is something of an intermediate
between baseball and basketball where
it's outdoors but people are in close
proximity to each other and that
includes on the practice field
the so i'm a huge buffalo bills fans for
anybody listening so i'm very excited
about the season and it is
very fitting that finally the buffalo
bills are favored to win the afc east
and then we
have kovid might not have a season so
there's that um
i think
i think we're gonna have football uh who
knows if mid-season it blows up
um but i think
you know the way the bills are handling
it they're like look it's just like part
this is part of our game right you gotta
prepare
um take care of your body and part of
that is wearing a mask or um
staying quarantined and things like that
um
also from a dollar since like there's a
lot of money on the line to have this
season so we'll see
um are you watching the nba playoffs
like i find them
like it sucks not having a crowd but i
do find them interesting
and the basketball's good particularly
down the stretch yeah
i've been watching the playoffs off and
on and
it is a different game it's interesting
um you're right the quality level's high
in part because the players
are just sleeping in the same beds and
not traveling anywhere and so they just
roll out of bed and
play each other at the same same jib two
days later
uh i talked to someone who is in the
bubble a player just came out
and uh he said it's tough in there
because
you you're reminded all the time that
you're in a bubble and you know your
families aren't there
though i know the families just showed
up but i i connected
someone in the nba to jacob blake's
family as well and
and uh so i've had some interaction with
some folks who are in the nba bubble
uh and it seems like its own world there
uh but i have been keeping up with it i
have been watching the games sometimes
right it's one one things we so we used
to go the buffalo bills used to go to st
john fisher's college
um for training camp and they stopped
because the
the recovery and workout equipment and
infrastructure
is so complicated now that that
university just didn't have it i'm one
i'm that'd be fascinating to see
you know i'm sure the lakers have a
state-of-the-art like training facility
and recovery rooms and things like that
i'm not sure that they're actually in
the walt disney bubble
like i'm actually very curious about the
health of the players post
post games particularly i'm not sure i
think the the trainers and the staffs
and the doctors all
are like they they have space in the
bubble they've got their own they've
stayed
okay they do have offices in the bubble
i mean if you got to see a specialist
here orthopedist
you know you leave so folks who are
interested in who in the nba
is yang gang aligned um
so jj redick our guy obviously has
donated 150k to universal basic income
trials thank you jj
thank you daryl mori donated to the yang
gang the campaign and was spotted
wearing a math hat in the bubble
uh so gm of the rockets
stan van gundy uh has been tweeting
positive things about us
lately so he's a massive member of the
coaching fraternity
uh and uh is someone that
that uh i think a lot of people look up
to and admire
so those are some of the folks that are
in the nba world that
uh we root for here at yang speaks
because you know that they uh
are very very enlightened folks or
you know who see that that we could
stand to do things
in a different way yeah so let's get
into it man i want to talk one of the
things we haven't talked about a lot
on this podcast is your views of the
2020 election
like you get to say some stuff on cnn
you get to say some stuff
frankly on other people's podcasts um
and we had a conversation with david
axelrod
two months ago something like that so a
lot has changed since you really dove in
um so high level i'll set the stage and
i love your thoughts so the dnc and the
rnc that
just had their conventions they happened
uh
you congratulations got to speak at the
dnc which was great
um thank you yang gang appreciate you
making it appreciate you
it's all because of you it wasn't easy
yep
and since the conventions and since your
conversation with axelrod
um the polls have tightened they've
tightened a bit and we knew they would
that makes sense um it's usually the
other way usually the incumbent
is in the lead and the challenger is
closing the race but in this case it's
the other way
um this is my takeaway from the
conventions i want your thoughts on this
election so
the democrats have a general message
which i think is that trump is unfit to
lead in covid
but if you looked at all their speakers
they did not all say that as
simply they said a bunch of things about
donald um it was not
in my opinion not as clear cut of a
message i didn't watch everything
probably the way you had to for cnn
but i did watch a lot um and then the
republicans i thought i don't like their
message but i think they're better at
saying it in the sense that every single
person on the rnc
said that the left is bad because
they're radical there's a radical left
is coming to get you
and your family and there's a lot of
fear-mongering i
i joked at the time i was like this
isn't exactly there's nothing to fear
but fear itself
instead it was uh you know feared a lot
of fear
fear the rampaging mobs in the suburbs
that will come you know like that that
was
yeah it's actually an explicit message
like you know there was
zero um pussyfooting around it they were
just like
and the mob is coming and it's
everything that happens
they can go back to this message right
everything that happens
um they just basically troll the left on
you know so anytime trump does something
stupid
or they get a bad press cycle that
normally happens to the oppo
any political party they can just take
any clip of any democrat they don't like
and just say this is the radical left
they're coming for you and it's fear
it's visceral and what i frankly i don't
love the message but i love the tactic
and that it's super
consistent you know what i'm saying like
that is a powerful
what we're rallying behind message which
i don't which is to me i'm terrified um
so a while ago you said
joe biden to be the next president
united states and you were saying it
like i looked at the numbers this is
what we got to do a lot of work but i
believe that's going to happen
have you changed your view like what do
you think this is a lock like where are
you at man
i'm still very optimistic that joe and
kamil are on track to win
uh their lead is also consistent it's
in the high single digits let's call it
seven or eight percent
uh the lead is smaller in swing states
but the swing states are very much up
for grabs
and trump needs to win essentially
most all of them in order to get
reelected
so i'm optimistic into your law and
order
message which i agree with zach i mean
they hammered it very very hard
joe actually has a polling advantage in
terms of people's
confidence about uh restoring a degree
of public order and decorum like
you know people have caught on that
trump is probably not the best
for clearing out some of these concerns
or reducing protests
or reducing violence so joe actually has
advantages among voters about restoring
public trust to restoring
peace addressing police brutality
trump's polling advantage consistently
is
on economic matters uh people still have
the sense of him as the
business guy so i don't think
this message is going to work for the
republicans
i i it's going to work on some people
obviously but i think it's going to work
uh to win and you have to respect their
message discipline
because i agree with you that they
settled on a message and then they went
for it
but i just think that most americans can
look at that message and be like wait a
minute
this is happening under trump do i
really think under four more years of
trump
like the the violence will go down as
opposed to up
um so there's some obvious
difficulty with the case they're trying
to make yeah
the i think a lot of
it's more of a moderate point i hear
pretty consistently
um from i guess my world is that
the polls aren't accurate not because
they can't get the right data
um because i think in the swing state
polls the state by state polls are
relatively accurate in 2016
relatively like within the margin of
error um
and and these are showing they were
showing hillary losing or barely winning
and now they're showing biden winning
or barely winning right it's kind of
where you're at um
but there's this sentiment i hear a lot
that is
basically no one will admit they're
voting for trump but when they get in
the polling booth they will
and i know there's this one because they
weren't the shy trump voters
yeah i know who they are um
i'm sure that there are a few i'm sure
there are a few shy trump voters out
there
um i don't think it's a this massive
it's on the margins yeah
to the extent that uh that there's a
uh concern right in front of us it
really is going to be around the process
itself
where are we going to know who on
november 3rd uh
when will we know who will declare
victory like how will various
institutions settle
on a winner uh will trump's
supporters uh claim victory no matter
what
uh you know like the the integrity of
the process to me is the biggest
unknown um but if you ask me do i think
joe biden is going to
get enough votes eventually over time
because we might not be able to count
them immediately
we've seen the vote counting issues in
new york and other places
uh like that that is the big question
mark uh one of the things that
538 said which i agree with um that this
is not so much an election day as it is
an election month
and that happens before the fact and
after the fact so before the fact there
are going to be a lot of states that
have
early voting and mainland voting so you
should take advantage i'm going to take
advantage everyone should take advantage
vote as soon as as you can and then
unfortunately it might stretch after
election day too because
some of the votes will uh not have been
counted yet and so some of the states
will
not be able to declare yeah you tweeted
that the other day it was good
um if you're
joe biden give me a question for both of
us we'll start you if you're joe biden
what are you doing to win like what do
you do in this dave axelrod called it
like see the ball into the glove
um like what if you're him what are you
doing right now he just started
traveling
um how would you handle it
uh i i think the traveling is optional
personally
you know i i i don't think that they
should try and fall into a trap where
it's like you know you have to barnstorm
the country or whatnot i mean people
understand the circumstances um
like that the main variables coming up
are the debates so
if if uh staying put for a week
or more is helpful to be prepared for
the debates which
having been through it you and i i know
like it might be
uh in terms of seeing the ball into the
glove
i like what they're doing in terms of
presenting their
plans their counterpoint to trump on
certain issues
on the economy and police brutality and
other issues
uh i think just maintaining a consistent
story and thread
um is right and um just letting people
know that
you know like you are joe biden you're
not some radical extremist
the rest of it uh and you are on track
to win i mean
they raised over 360 million dollars uh
last month which i believe might be a
record
um and so they they can not to say i
mean like we all hate it when people
start playing like where they're like
coasting at the end like you know
there's no coasting here
um but campaign smart uh keep on
um putting out your own vision for
what the country should be doing uh and
then prepare for the debates
yeah i think he has to hold his own of
the debates
um big time and then to me if i was joe
biden's team which
to be fair like i think they're well run
i've the people i've interacted with
um at the senior levels that campaign
which we have a good relationship with
are are talented and smart um i would
say
if i was joe's team i would find a a
phrase
like they're they're going with the like
we're the good guy this guy's unfit to
lead like that's kind of the message
they're going with i would find a clever
way to say that
um almo not gimmicky but in a way that's
catchy and interesting
and i would tie everything back to that
every single thing um
and i think they do that but not as well
as the republicans do because right now
they just tie
everything back to the radical left
coming for your kids radical f burning
up your cbs soon
um like and i say that
when we were running andrew we our
thread line no matter what when it was
when it was horrible people come at us
from the woodwork we had
the bait moderators not ask you
questions like whatever the [ __ ] was
thrown at us what do we go back to
you would say i'm the magical asian man
wants to give everybody a thousand a
month but it was a thousand dollars a
month right like and it was
this is our why and it's so important in
politics like i'm not running to deal
with the nonsense i'm this is the
message
and we were able to lean on that often
almost daily
um i don't know if the dems have that
simply articulated i could be wrong the
trumps was make america great again
um and that sounds gimmicky but it
worked um
i think joe's message to your point is
ready to lead
you know or fit to lead like like that
that would be like the
the message and then in contrast they
they're saying trump is unfit to lead
which
right that's and that's not a bad one
ready day one like let's like fix this
mess like there's a million ways ago and
they're kind of doing it
um well the way they frame it zak
which it sounds like you don't love is
battle for the soul of the country
yeah which i don't love um
because if we win we gotta hit moderates
and
um independents and republicans right
that's how you win
don't know i'm reading that righteous
mind book by jonathan hate we're trying
i want to get on the podcast
it's just how democrats and republicans
talk differently because of who they are
like biologically it's fascinating go
ahead andrew sorry i was very much
influenced by that book
we're definitely going to get john on
here i'll i'll invite him today
all right how have i missed this
jonathan's going on sweet
yeah so um i've never loved the battle
for this all the country
uh frame yeah
but you know you have to say i mean like
he was running on that in the primaries
and
it worked yeah like restore the
celebration
and he's a good guy for that i mean i i
like i like the biden team because they
stick to their guns and they know what
they're doing they don't get caught up
in the weeds and the daily nonsense so
um
and uh there's other campaigns but we'll
not we won't mention but they got
caught up in that all the time and most
of the time they end up dropping out you
end up getting crushed when you do that
um so we go on all day on
our opinions on political strategy um
well you know i'm optimistic on 2020
uh with the big unknown being the
process itself
um but i think that you know we keep on
working and grinding
uh there's cause for optimism in
november and
beyond and boy knows lord knows we need
it you know
[Music]
when i was running for president i slept
on a lot of mattresses
there were a lot of mattresses involved
we never got bed bugs which was
especially in the early days a minor
mirror thank goodness for that airbnb
uh hotels motels whatever it was
i gotta say a good mattress makes a
pretty freaking huge difference
and if you want uh the mattress of the
future that's personalized to you that
you get ordered and it comes in a box
then it pops out
like some kind of uh animate mattress
what are helix sleep it's great we've
got one
you personalize it to to you it gets
sent to your door
is the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired so if that
doesn't make you excited for helix sleep
they'll also just take it back if you
don't like it
it's almost too good to be true go to
helixsleep.com
yang and take their two minute sleep
quiz who doesn't want to answer
questions about how you sleep
uh and they'll match you to a customized
mattress i thoroughly enjoyed that by
the way yeah yeah it's fun
it makes you think about it the clip the
quiz is awesome it's like do i sleep on
my back no i see them on my side
anyway keep going yeah i know you think
about it i'm a front sleeper myself no
i'm not
front sleepers are no i really i
actually i don't even know what that was
you're a sleep anywhere guy if the
campaign bus is any indication
you are i'm asleep all positions
standing at any time you give me a
chance
crouched uh yeah so so helix is offering
up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com yang that's helix h e
l i x
sleep.com for up to 200 off
[Applause]
um so this is less optimistic but it was
really touching um
so you got to speak to
the family of jacob blake who was the um
the black man shot by the a cop in
kenosha wisconsin he was shot seven
times in the back
um on video and it's it's a horrifying
video and so you got to
and to be clear we stand with that we
stand with jacob's family and you got to
speak with
jacob's father i believe right and his
uncle did you
um we talked about on cnn a bit but tell
us more about that conversation and what
you
what you lived oh my gosh what a what a
moment yeah they
reached out uh and i was
you know touched that they wanted to
hear from me so i said of course like
you know i'll call him as soon as
possible talk to his father and uncle
uh his father was
anguished but he also said it was really
happy and joyous to be able to touch his
son like just physically touch him
in the hospital like hold his hand uh he
did tell me that
that jacob blake jr's first words to him
were
uh daddy why did they shoot me so many
times and he
cried and so imagine being a father and
having your son
cry to you in the hospital in that way
and his son his son remembered being
shot five times and not the sixth and
the seventh i imagine because he
lost consciousness uh
so that that was the the story uh his
father was clearly very upset
i have to say that uh no like
like periodically like i don't see that
much of the stuff i i get on social
media and whatnot but there are all
these folks being like jacob blake did
this jacob like did that it's like are
you
[ __ ] me it's like did you see what
happened like just in the sense that
like you would have to have done
something insane
uh you know for anyone to think that
like you know you're being
like having lethal force directed at you
would make sense
much less getting shot seven times in
the back as you're
trying to reach into the car that your
kids are inside i mean like the whole
thing um the the fact that folks and so
the message that jacob lake
uh senior had was just tell him when my
son's a human being
and like as a human being who saw what
happened to
uh to another human being it's
reprehensible and awful
and the the fact that his father was
anguished over the fact that
you know we saw his son paralyzed on
video uh and
the prognosis is that uh he may never
walk again
uh now it was heart-wrenching
um i never expected to
to have that conversation and then
essentially
um be given a charge saying because that
like look if you want to share this
conversation with others like you know
we think that would be uh something that
we'd be
very open to or positive about and then
i said well if you want me to
share this story i'd be glad to i'd feel
uh honored to and what uh
so it's so heartbreaking and so i'm a um
i grew up listening to mike and mike on
in the morning on espn
um and i was always a huge i like golic
but mike greenberg is one i was a big
fan of and he said something on his own
show the other day
about this he was talking about the nba
protests um after
jacob was was shot and um
what he said was that the imperfection
of the messenger
does not mean you ignore the message
and that's where i think we get lost
where
like anywhere from like jacob blake had
a criminal record
to like the shut up and dribble bs that
they give professional athletes like
if you're and his important and i
believe so strongly if you're focused on
their imperfections
or what's wrong with them or why they're
not perfect or the mistakes they've made
in their life and missing the bigger
point the fact that we just canceled the
freaking
nba basketball season because of this
you're missing
like you're you're so off you're part of
the problem um
and it's so frustrating when something
tragic happens you're like oh but he
wasn't a saint like who the hell is a
saint who the hell can stand
up there and be like oh i was i was
perfect never just you know like does it
just because
even if you're a criminal you don't
deserve to be shot in the back seven
times damn it
what is wrong i'm sorry i'm getting all
10 but what is wrong with us or that
that is a
rational discussion point well i
i think zach and this actually comes up
in the righteous mind
to an extent that if something terrible
happens to
a human being in front of your eyes
there is a human impulse to say well
maybe i can find some explanation for
this that's not just that this was a
terrible injustice
interesting and and so people people
grope for that
um it's not right you know in this case
and
i to me it's like you look on the face
and say this was
i'm brutally inhuman but that that is
just an
impulse that folks naturally have your
point yeah
it's like cognitive dissonance in some
way in an odd way um
and this is so something i think is
really important to bring up and i want
to be clear before i bring it up like we
are
we've been supportive of black lives
matter and the protests at humanity
forward
as people individually as professionals
um but i want to talk about what the
republicans are doing with these
protests so right now the protests are
at times generally peaceful but at times
violent um
there is looting there is i mean people
have died on the streets during these
protests
there's a massive distinction between
protests and
looting you know what i mean like like
when i think protests i i think of
folks who are marching and speaking and
demonstrating
and then there's a whole nother segment
of behavior of uh looting
destruction rioting uh violence
like i i see those as distinct do you
think
cnn or the mainstream media sees those
as distinct
yeah i i think that most media
organizations are trying to figure out
how to
distinguish really where there are
protests happening all over the country
in various ways that you
don't see or hear anything about because
they were peaceful
and folks just demonstrated and you know
showed up
and that to me describes the vast vast
majority
of the behaviors around the country and
what we're seeing and then you have
some bad act actions and actors um some
driven by
passion that's connected to the
protests some just because you know that
they've they've been looking for
uh an excuse or catalyst
to to engage in various behaviors
uh and and then you see people on the
other side
like engaging something similar where
you think okay well there's this
protest let me go counter protest so you
end up with outliers
often people who don't live in the
actual community like if you look at
the the yeah so that to me is another
distinction we should draw
is that if there are folks in kenosha
who show up many of whom might actually
even know
like someone who's been personally
affected by this like that's a very very
different picture than
folks who are from another part of the
country who drive in and then
participate
uh and often have agendas where like
if they can uh cause trouble then that's
uh frankly like a big part of the reason
they're there
uh and and so that that's like a very
very big distinction
and the the danger is that people just
try and uh conflate
these different people these different
activities
uh these different types of
actions uh together and that's actually
to me what the republicans have been
doing is just trying to put everything
with a broad brush
paint everything with a broad brush and
say look you know anarchist mob
or whatnot and and uh and then you look
at it and say wait a minute like there
are a lot of people who are just
showing up because they think uh what
happened to jacob blake
or george floyd is wrong and we need
that we need to address and change it i
mean like
which in many ways you're
glad for because can you imagine a
country where you see people's lives get
extinguished and everyone just shrugs
and like
stays home and just watches another
video yeah i mean like like that would
be
a terrible uh reaction
like the protests are in many ways like
a more
human empathetic reaction uh
and then just trying to paint it with a
broad brush and saying well and then
also there are these bad actors like
doing the
or not painter just say that like that
everyone's a mob
um like that that just feeds some of the
abstract discussion around this stuff
that i just don't think is productive or
helpful
you know if you you have to try and suss
out different actors different groups
different motivations
different geographies and
it's one reason why i think that the
confusion around this
is uh is corrosive
yeah and you have a lot of people not
paying as much attention to them as as
you do or i do or a lot of us do
to me is this vicious cycle that's
really frustrating to me to watch where
you've got a criminal justice system
where frankly black americans are
treated differently than white americans
so much so that they're occasionally
being shot while unarmed right
and that people are so mad at this that
they're rising up and they're protesting
right and then you have the people in
power
in charge of the system are inciting
that violence they're like go get them
law and order
camera ball like or [ __ ] on it or
whatever it is and then
because of that you get more animosity
more anger more protests more and more
and then what that party in power is
doing is using that to scare
people who are not protesting or their
average voter who's not
an activist not getting involved these
protests use that to scare them
and possibly stay in power you know what
i'm saying this like vicious
like the more the protests happen the
more the rights using against the left
and i don't know what to do and solve on
that
how to solve that well the the main
thing is to try and distinguish again
between
demonstrations and protests and uh
violence
yeah and and worse uh but van jones put
it in a way that i thought was really
apt he said look um there there are
three
forms of uh criminality that we have to
try and address
number one is excesses on the part of
police where you say look
like this stuff was uh not why you put
an officer
you know in a position to
serve and protect so that's category
number one is
police accesses number two
is demonstrations that lead to riots and
violence
which is not the vast majority of them
but you know that there is some
proportion and then number three is
uh vigilantism and folks coming in
uh trying to pick fights
or or worse yeah and so if you're yeah
if you're trying to
to install a sense of
uh of order and peace
you have to try and address all three uh
and
the the folks on the the right
seem very concerned with number two but
not concerned with one or three
uh and that is really the problem is
that if you were
a reasonable leader you would look up
and say okay like none of these things
is acceptable
uh we can't have police just shooting
unarmed civilians in the back
uh in front of all of us we can't have
people rioting and looting and
destroying
and we can't have vigilantes crossing
state lines
uh and uh engaging in violent behaviors
like none of these things is
corrupt is right or good or productive
or helpful or leading us any place
positive
right that that's like a reasonable
approach to it all and
but you can't just home in on one and
say this one is
the sole problem um because you know
they each
require different approaches one of the
things
i always like working with you on is you
understand nuance better than most
people
or how things are complicated and
understand the gray
because i think a lot of our political
parties we go right or left or like
right or wrong
black and white um the reality is always
more complicated
um so let me shift gears a little bit
but not too much you
um i wanna i always like to take one of
your tweets from
last time we recorded and that was
popular and you said something
about chadwick um bozeman who he
mentioned the top of the episode i said
you said
your quote was you think someone like
chadwick is on top of the world
and they're actually fighting for their
life in private everyone is human
to me this is exactly what we're talking
about like it's not black or white it's
not superstar
or human being it's he's a superstar
who's also a human being right like
there's
there's
nuance there what did you mean when you
tweeted that i know that it's like
you've talked about mental health i know
that's deeper what does you mean
well it's tough because if you're in the
public eye
um and i've been a public figure now for
a relatively brief period of time
you know where there's like a chadwick
but yeah yeah um
and there there's a sense that you are
not human
in the like that you are rich or you're
famous or
you know your life is great um you don't
have human concerns
problems struggles uh and you do
and chadwick when i first saw the
headline that he'd passed
like you know i was like that can't be
right because
like i feel like i saw him just you know
a number of months ago in this film or
that film and i'd heard absolutely
nothing about
him being ill and he's relatively young
and healthy in the rest of it um and it
wasn't like a
car accident or something like that like
it was literally disbelief
but one of the things that i've learned
is that the human condition
is universal that uh even if you said to
young andrew yang it's like hey
in the future you'll run for president
and uh
like all these things would happen then
i would have been like wow
like you know my life must be
be incredible and you know and then and
my life is incredible in many respects
uh that you know i get to do
uh do positive things and and trying to
help people
uh but at the end of the day you know
it's still
um like did i make breakfast for the
kids like you know
like are there kids in uh on track to um
to learn anything today that's not
totaled crap
um you know yeah is is my wife
uh am i happy are we having some quality
time together uh am i
myself mentally healthy or uh physically
healthy or the rest of it like all of
the things that apply to
just being alive still very much apply
no matter who you are
uh and right now one of the the dangers
we have that you
you related just a moment ago was people
are just so
eager to throw rocks at each other you
know and it's like if there
is like someone who makes a social media
post
then there are folks who just claim
around and be like oh that was
wrong and sensitive you missed this like
you know you're not using your
uh like that it's like meanwhile it's
like the human being on the other hand
is just like
i was just making an observation you
know like we still have to try and
remember that we're all uh we're all
still people at the other side of it
um one of the things that i take pride
in is that i think folks had a sense
even as i was running for president that
i was a
fairly normal guy normal human
um and i've now met a number of people
who are public figures
and the best of them are
still you know themselves they're still
like a relatively
not normal because they can't you know
most of them know that they're not
normal or whatever but
you know like that they're they're not
[ __ ] they're not like
total automatons um and a lot of them
are very sensitive
like a lot of them yeah you know they
really take stuff to heart in a way
you're like oh
snap because i think that's one of the
things that's going on too is that
you think if there's some celebrity it's
like i'm gonna [ __ ] talk them on social
media it's like they're not gonna care
like a shocking number of them actually
if they saw it it would bother them
[Laughter]
like they'll see it and be like oh like
that you know
people really think that you can't it's
human nature you know
yeah so so i think chad uh
passing like it's just a reminder it's
like man people are going through things
you have no idea like i never would have
guessed that chadwick boseman was
struggling on that level
uh and i know like we just found out the
rock and his family had coveted the
other end of it it's like you know you
never think these things
um so just try and have some
uh give people the benefit of the doubt
just imagine that maybe they're going
through some things
maybe they're having a bad day and you
know if they say something you disagree
with like i hope we get to a point where
people can shrug it off and be like well
you know that wasn't my cup of tea but
um
you know it's like who knows what that
what's going on on the other end
this stuff is actually biblical man i
talk about you know he with no sin cast
the first stone or
you know you're pointing out the speck
in my eye without looking at the stake
in yours
i'm paraphrasing but um i i agree man
and
one of the reasons i am very very
supportive of joe biden this cycle is
because
and i think a lot of republicans may
have felt this like i thought donald yes
divisive but i thought he was going to
be like rise the occasion as the
like it's all about me but i can be the
the uniting leader as president and he's
been the exact opposite the entire time
and maybe i should have read that and
maybe a bunch of others but
to me like whether you love joe's policy
or even love the guy
like he's not going to rip us apart the
way that's happening right now
and we need to come together because it
doesn't the virus doesn't care if you're
left or right it doesn't matter
republican democrat didn't care about
your skin killer it's killing everybody
um and i'm sick of being in my studio
apartment i'm sick of that i'd like to
get out
um so that's why i think
you'd get some the right type of
leadership ignoring policy and political
party
if you put a binding administration in
there well we have to
help people dig out and like it or not
the government
in my mind has to take a major major
leadership role
in that and i just do not see that
happening under trump
uh will that necessarily happen under
joe and kamala i certainly hope so
at least we give ourselves a chance one
of the things that we're going to be
talking about a lot on
yang speaks over the next number of
weeks is trying to fix the machine of
government
uh because that that's one of my new
areas of attention and focus
in part because uh and i i said this
recently it said like
you know fixing the machine is as or
more important than who's in the cockpit
like you get the right person in
leadership and
the government just can't get anything
done then nothing will get done and then
we'll just continue to get angry at each
other
and fed up and then be like oh and i
think this is one reason why trump was
elected and it's
legitimate is that people are just
looking up being like man like this is
not working for me like dc is not
working for me
uh it has not been working for you for
quite some time and
and that that is to me a very very
legitimate point of view
uh and that has to be something that we
dig deep and try and address
um so that that's where i believe
the opportunity and challenge meet um
where
it's going to be hard like i think joe
and kamala are going to win
um and then in many ways the harder
challenge is going to be whether
they can get our government to to
to meet the challenge the
you want the government to be somewhat
of a cruise ship in the sense that it
doesn't matter who's driving it
generally speaking um that
it can still get from point a to point b
it can still float
like people who pay like still are
satisfied like that's what you
and like fortune 500 companies have
worked at a big a big one i worked at
ubs and
through suit up interact with a lot of
them they're all like that it doesn't
matter who you put
and some of these big companies around
forever it doesn't matter in many ways
you put at the top
because they've built this mode around
their business and it's just
exist and i hated that when i worked
there but
i'd so much rather have the cruise ship
where no one wants to change anything
and it's just running then the titanic
where it's actively sinking and because
of bad leadership and
no one knows what's going on half the
people don't think it's sinking god it's
a disaster
um we have to get to cruise ship i think
if we're going to keep that analogy i
don't know
i know i get it uh yeah so fixing the
machinery is going to be our new jam
and one person who really fixed the
machinery in his own
company is our guest on yang speaks this
week
the co-founder and ceo of gravity
payments
dan price and if you're a price standing
member
of the yang gang then you know dan
price's story but dan price made
national headlines
for having a minimum salary at his
company of seventy thousand dollars
a year he said look if you work for me
then you should make at least this much
and people around the country were
shocked he became this massive cause
uh celeb and there are folks on the
right i think it was rush limbaugh who
were like i can't wait to see the
company fail
uh and then if they checked in they'd
see that the company
grew and and became very prosperous i
believe it tripled in size or more
uh so dan and i met at a rally in
seattle
when i was running for president um he
is one of the pioneers
and champions of a more advanced form of
capitalism
uh it's like a version of human-centered
capitalism
i loved talking to dan what a visionary
what a human
like a human beacon of light and hope
and the the great thing about him is
that you know
there could be many many more like him
um if we just put ourselves in position
to reward that kind of leadership
um so really excited to share my
conversation
with one of the originals of
human-centered capitalism
ceo of gravity payment scan price
[Music]
and now let's do something that i am
super pumped about doing something fun
so so anyone who is a big fan of yank
speaks may have heard these ads for
these electric scooters unagi that i
cruise around on
on most days uh they are game changers
they are so
fun they're environmentally friendly
they're electric
in a time of coved you can scoot around
on these things
and uh you know like you're you're on
your own you can just breathe the the
opening masks you're moving so fast away
from people it's great
and you're not going to believe this but
we are now going to give away
an unagi scooter to someone who follows
me and zach grauman on instagram and tag
three people in comments that's like a
thousand dollar
electric scooter it's like the iphone or
tesla of scooters
one of them is going away for free we're
going to do this multiple weeks but this
first week
instagram follow at andrew yang and at
zac growlman
and tag three people in the comments
then you might end up cruising around on
the scooter we can swap photos
and enjoy the scooter madness together
this is gonna be awesome so we're gonna
post this on instagram
follow us both and tag three friends
and we're gonna fill this out we got a
great digital team they'll find you
winner gets a free scooter and they're
sick so
um instagram andrew yang and at zac
graumann tag three friends we made some
hurdles because
one we would like to grow our instagram
platforms let's be real but two
we think a lot of you will want it so we
wanted to the true believers and people
really wanted to put their name in this
thing
so check it out unagi giveaway um and
now enjoy an episode of dan price
all right fantastic i am thrilled to
welcome
to yang speaks one of the leaders of
the future economy uh
a human ceo who's made national news for
treating employees like human beings
imagine that right the novelty the ceo
of gravity payments mr dan price dan
welcome to yank speaks
andrew it is such an honor to be on yang
speaks i'm really um happy and excited
for all the hard work that your team
continues to do and i just appreciate
the opportunity
to talk to you are you kidding i
appreciate you dan and you and i
met in seattle on the trail that rally
was one of the first big rallies we had
like an eagle
came overhead and joined the yang gang
for those of you that don't know there
was literally a bald eagle
circling over andrew's head yes thank
you bald eagle
for blessing the rally um well that
rally was awesome you
spoke uh it was relatively early in the
campaign
and i i was grateful to you and everyone
who
saw the campaign early on and in your
case it makes sense because of what you
stand for i mean you've made all these
incredible
decisions well before the campaign came
about
but what was your history with universal
basic income and when did you first
notice the
andrew yang campaign you know um
early early on when you started
campaigning when you went on joe rogan
and sam harris's show and a few others a
lot of people reached out to me and they
were like hey this guy's saying
basically the same stuff that you're
saying like you need to check him out
because he's running for president
and obviously i remember you know you
started running for president
basically before anybody else that ended
up being in the primary
and so people were just telling me about
this guy that was saying a lot of the
same things
but to be honest i was not super
educated about universal basic income so
your campaign helped me tremendously and
i was
i was kind of always like you say kind
of aligned with it but i didn't really
understand the ex's nose until you came
around
well that makes a lot of sense to me and
it makes me happy to hear that i might
have
helped um you realize that ubi is very
aligned to your vision for the way the
economy should operate
um and i'd love to talk about your
background too because there are a lot
of folks
um are you a parent uh dan
no i hope to be one day but not yet well
i'm sure you will i mean if you hope to
be like you know
you can make that happen but i
was going to raise the fact that um you
are homeschooled in idaho i believe and
i feel like there's so many parents
around the country that are
homeschooling their kids
uh right now either voluntarily or
involuntarily because they're they're a
lot of schools that have
um shut down so i'd love to ask you
about your opera your
experience growing up well i was the
fourth of six kids
and i was raised in rural idaho kind of
like out between like farms and just
like barren land
my next door neighbor was a dump uh in
pickle butte idaho
and um you know so it was a very unusual
uh
upbringing i had uh three hours of rush
limbaugh every day was part of the
homeschooling and then also
two to three hours of bible study every
day so it was it was pretty rigorous
um and uh being the fourth of six kids
where neither one of my parents
graduated from
from college you know they had a they
had their hands full
and and it was tough so we were kind of
largely
self-schooled and so i would say that
probably
you know in some ways it's not
necessarily the example that we need
right now
but um i do think how can i get my kid
to grow up like dan price
i was thinking i need to find a dump
gotta get that rush limbaugh programming
on
i mean i will say i do think there's a
point there which is you kind of have to
use the reality that you have as opposed
to the reality you want so none of us
of course want this pandemic none of us
want you know our school kids to be
disrupted and all those things but we
can
teach our kids through this opportunity
we can teach them about
ubi about human dignity
about basic needs all these things right
now
that maybe kind of would get
shortchanged a little bit if schools
were open and we didn't have this big
issue to deal with
i certainly hope that we end up teaching
our kids something
different during this time so when was
the first time you showed up to
an actual school and what was that
experience like
well i was in seventh grade and i
remember a kid telling me that i was
wearing the wrong shoes
um and that's why the other kids were
making fun of me so i saved up a bunch
of money to to get the shoes and
fortunately payless had a two-for-one
shoe sale and i showed up with my shoes
that looked like the other kid's shoes
and they explained to me that because
their shoes said vans and my said paid
less it still didn't work so it was
it was tough you know it was it was
difficult figuring out how to get
socialized
how to like um i mean i think actually
there's so much conformity in our
society today that's pre-programmed in
at a young age
and it was really jarring for me to all
of a sudden have to know all those
lessons that i had no opportunity to
learn
well it's one reason why i want to delve
into your background because you're such
a singular
ceo and a lot of the practices you've
adopted at your company
are unconventional they've proven to be
hugely successful and so
uh you're right about the conformity and
so you know how does the non-conformist
entrepreneur
uh develop um so in your case you showed
up
seventh grade you were like whoa these
kids have been hanging out with each
other an
awful lot while i've been at home uh
and so um what was that process like
through
junior high and high school did you feel
at some point you were like okay now i
get people
like how long does it take to get people
well i
i had a bit of a rocky process because i
went from being socially awkward to
starting a rock band with two of my best
friends in junior high
and our rock band was successful we were
played on very tiny radio stations
nationwide we did little mini regional
tours and everything
so i went from being socially awkward to
being on stage and that that was a
really like jarring process
and honestly i had to go through just a
lot of pain and turmoil and
understanding that the way i was coming
across was a little bit different than
how people were perceiving me
and i think if you ask some people that
know me really well they might say i'm
still trying to figure that out today
okay so you get there you're like i've
got the wrong shoes these kids seem to
be
talking in a way that uh i don't get um
i'm gonna start a rock band and so what
was your band um first
like were you the front kid like the the
cigarette guitarist
what were you i was the least talented
musician by a mile in the band but my
dad you know like i said he didn't have
a college degree but he
he worked his way up in a medium-sized
company actually about the same size
that gravity is today
and he was always trying to teach
himself about business and he was such a
great student in terms of like
being self-taught and so he let me kind
of ride along with him as a kid so i
learned the seven habits of highly
effective people when i was maybe eight
or nine years old wow
and and i applied a lot of that stuff
into the band and so
i think the band appreciated me more
kind of from a business standpoint than
a musical standpoint which broke my
heart of course
you were like half drummer half manager
yeah exactly and it was weird because i
could kind of get along with adults
really well from like socializing with
my parents but like the kid thing i
couldn't figure out and that was always
a bit of a disconnect for me but then
when my band broke up my junior year of
high school it was a really natural
transition to me
to actually start a business or start
building a business
as a high school kid because it allowed
me to go work with
really the people that i think about
every day which are all the small
business owners out there that are kind
of like yeah
zany and off the wall but they do so
many amazing things for us in our
society
i love small business owners so much i i
ran a small business myself for a number
of years and it's where i kind of came
of
age as a
an adult so you started
a business in high school then that that
was uh what kind of business was that
it's the same business i have today i
officially launched it my freshman year
of college
um but i started building it so
basically you know what we do for those
of you that don't know
out there in the audience is credit card
processing so it's kind of boring but
all these small businesses have to pay a
ton of money just to get paid on a
credit card
which of course is totally unfair and so
my original business was just kind of
like calling all the credit card
companies and
kind of convincing them trying to
persuade them to give all of these
business owners that i knew a better
rate
but i took the money i made from that
business and started building my own
product so i wouldn't be reliant on
those huge monopoly companies
so you started that in high school you
went to college in seattle right which
is where you are now
and then you were running the business
uh the whole time
and growing it um your brother worked
alongside you on that business right you
had a partner
yeah he he helped me start it uh or we
started together i should say it was
really kind of his idea to partner up
together and and do it together yeah
so i'm gonna guess you were not the most
diligent college student just a guess
i had a i got a copy and paste letter in
college that i would send my professors
and i would say hey i'm on i'm on the
dean's list i've been on the dean's list
every quarter
but my attendance record is about 40 is
that okay with you or not and if they
said no i'd say no problem i'll just
take the class from another professor
okay so you were attendance light and
you managed to cram for the tests
and then the whole time you were
building the business
so when was it clear to you that uh
that the business was going to be what
you did
it might have been clear for the whole
time um where you knew that it wasn't
like at the end of college you were like
oh
time to polish a resume and like get out
there and apply for a job it sounds like
that was never in the cards for you is
that right
no because i grew up thinking i'd be a
professional musician
and not just thinking about kind of
knowing like that was my destiny and
then
once i found in the band that i loved
dealing with all the small business
owners
i kind of actually found that even
though i loved music so much my talent
was more in that and so
i just wanted to work with all those
small business owners my whole life
now when i actually figured out that
that could be sustainable financially
maybe is a slightly different question
but early on even in high school i was
like i would love to just do everything
i can
because i in my mind if i spent my
entire life just trying to help out
small businesses
that would be pretty much the best way i
could spend it
i get it man i love small business
owners so much i had this experience
i was an unhappy lawyer and then i went
in to
visit with the ceo of a small company
and i said to myself i want to be that
guy like however the heck you become
the head of a small business because he
had like this
you know his office and the set of
employees and he was responsible for
them
and he felt like
uh like what i wanted to become and so
you think to yourselves like how the
heck do i become that person
i have this deep deep uh
for small business owners because i
understand what it means to just get up
and then open the diner every day and
then have
everyone um come to you for with their
problems
and have to make decisions on shifts or
compensation and so when i became the
head of a
company myself well i i so i don't know
how much you know about this but like i
co-founded a
dot-com that crashed and burned in my
mid-20s then i worked at
a wireless software company and then a
healthcare software company and then i
became the head
of an education company and when i
finally became ceo of this company i was
30 or 31
so much older than you are now much i
mean you're much older than you were
when you started i mean you're one of
those
it became such like this pure experience
where you felt like you're the head of a
family
because there are dozens even hundreds
of
people that count on you to make the
right decisions
about the business but also about them
their responsibilities whether they get
a promotion or a raise whether team's
not working and you have to make a
change like all these things like you're
making these decisions every day
and i just grew up like you know i feel
like these small businesses
um put uh put on their
people like this particularly the
leaders like you are this very very pure
set of responsibilities
uh you know and it's it's a beautiful
process that really grows you in
particular ways
yeah it's i like the way you're saying
it like the rubber really meets the road
when you're doing it
what was it that attracted you when you
met that first like small business owner
that made you say you wanted to do that
he just seemed like
he was doing his own thing and making
his own decisions
and there wasn't like this some
corporate headquarters that he was
answering to
that he had to check in with it it was
just like he
you know and and that the people around
him
felt like they were going to either
succeed or fail
based upon what he uh decided
and they were totally comfortable with
that
it was like that kind of feeling like
wow he's like he was like you can get
things done
yeah he was like the captain of a ship
and just
exuded uh like a sense of
quiet confidence just like you dan
[Laughter]
very few people have called me quiet but
i'll take that as a huge compliment
or just like like you you kind of get
this vibe from
a lot of small business owners you know
because you have to make all these
decisions every day you have to evaluate
people
you have to interview people and be like
you're hired you're not hired like
you just have to make so many decisions
that you do develop
a certain decision-making confidence and
and small businesses are so on the rope
right now and i i wanted to ask you
about this a little bit because
you know in in some of the reading and
writing that i've been doing
like we found that there's been just a
massive transfer
of of revenue of commerce of wealth you
know you have
some of these companies like amazon um
and square and and apple and all these
huge behemoth companies
the two trillion dollar company yeah and
yet
small businesses our data shows that
small businesses are down on average
about 20 plus percent
and 30 have permanently closed at this
point and that's growing
and what i worry about and i want to
know what you think about this is how do
we put that genie back in the bottle
because the trend just seems really hard
right now
you need to dramatically rebalance the
economy if you're going to give small
businesses a chance to
reopen or open a new so you would need
something like universal basic income
honestly to have a shot
because you have apple breaking 2
trillion you have amazon just sucking
so many businesses dry at this point and
it angers me dan when
you see congress bring the ceos in to
testify
and they they still are kind of
pretending that they're like these
scrappy little companies and be like oh
i remember when i got started and it was
pretty dicey there
it's like come on you're worth a
trillion dollars now like
at this point uh your business
has left orbit and you're like defying
the laws of business physics
uh you know like tim o'reilly called it
super money
where where how could you compete with a
company that
is worth a trillion dollars and doesn't
even need to make money
like in any given period you know like
if there's anything interesting coming
up they're like oh maybe i'll buy that
for a billion dollars worth of stock and
and then they act like oh we could be
jeopardized at any moment like all
consumers could just turn away from us
like it's very tenuous please don't
uh actually investigate our
anti-competitive behaviors
so like that the whole thing is
infuriating because
uh because small businesses are getting
the oxygen sucked out of their
um their rooms and look they're just
gasping for air and they can't breathe
and you're seeing it because you have a
dashboard into
the real life operations of thousands of
small businesses
um so they're gasping for and dying and
then amazon is like oh
i guess we're going to turn this
abandoned mall into a fulfillment
warehouse and fill it with robots and
the rest of it i mean
like all of the the understandings that
people have about the way businesses
operate have changed because of
these big tech companies unprecedented
level of power in particular
the the shift has been heartbreaking for
me because you know my clients i've
known them my our first thousand clients
i knew over half on a first name basis
have access to like each other's cell
phones and everything
and hearing from you know some of these
people that have just spent their whole
life and all their life savings and
risks so much
just kind of feel like they're in like
this kind of zombie status now
because of that oxygen that you talked
about obviously there's demand
side which ubi addresses really really
well
but there's also this other side which
is like in the bailout
you know you had warren buffett going
out there and saying oh i took a hundred
billion dollars just because they
offered it to me for free so why
wouldn't i do it
and then you have these main street
small businesses that yeah then maybe
they got the ppp but that's run out at
this point and so they don't really have
that same
assistance that same attention from the
people in power and the big companies
are just ruthless and able to in being
able to use that advantage to
permanently shift market share in their
direction
now i suggested something even more
targeted where i said we should be
getting universal basic income that we
can only use at locally owned businesses
and then you could create
uh kind of these mini economies and i
feel like many americans would
love just to be able to plow money into
like the local
restaurant or bar tutoring service or
dog walker or what have you because they
know
they know a lot of those people often
times
but then when push comes to shove if you
yourself don't have disposable income
and there's another thing that makes me
mad dan it's like i'm all for the like
shop small campaigns and the rest of it
but pretending that some kind of little
voluntary market tweak like oh if we all
just try a little bit harder to support
those small businesses
then like the 20 billion dollar black
hole to amazon every year will reverse
itself it's like no
it's not the way this [ __ ] works at all
like i'm all for it
but you know like we should be trying to
support these small business owners but
we shouldn't pretend like that's going
to do the trick
when you're talking about historic
shifts at this level
yeah i think that's true and i think
there's just so much incentive to kind
of join the other side
you know i even in my shoes um you know
i get
emails on the regular from like
investment bankers
and you know someone wants to freaking
make you a deal you can't refuse dan
because they'd be like hey dan
you know what would be great just take
that check get gobbled up into the
mothership borg and like uh you know
join us i'm sure your
70k minimum salary will will uh be
completely accepted by the new parent
company
get outsourced those jobs will get
automated outsourced
and the the experience of the small
business client that we're like in the
streets fighting for every day will get
worse they won't have somebody like us
out there
you know doing everything we can to set
up them up with contactless payments
with mobile payments
pay from your car all these things that
we're doing for all these industries
kind of go away
but i think what concerns me the most
i mean look everything that you've been
saying that would happen has already
happened and i recognize that this is
more of like a here and now
versus when you first started saying it
it was somewhat in the future
but like i worry about the next shoe
that's gonna drop
is just this situation where there's so
much monopoly type behavior there's so
much bait and switch type behavior
and we all kind of go around in life
getting nickeled and dimed by these huge
companies
where we have no ability to hold them
accountable and anybody like me that
comes along and says i want to be part
of the other team they say
hey you can we can take all that stress
away from you and give you more money
than you
ever know what to do with and you can
just have a smile ear to ear every day
you just gotta sell out and join this
system
i'm so glad you're describing this dan
because it's true for
you it's true for so many i'm gonna tell
a story that broke my heart where
there's this
uh person who owned uh seven grocery
stores in new jersey
family business owned operated just you
know like
and when amazon bought whole foods
he said you know what i'm going to take
all the profits from my grocery stores
and just start buying amazon stock
because i give up
like there is not going to be me
competing with
these guys over time i'm just going to
to accept
that the grocery stores of the future
are going to be owned by the trillion
dollar company
that i cannot compete with it used to be
i invested in my stores it used to be i
invested my people
used to be maybe i even bought a new
grocery store consolidated or opened
something he's like now
like none of that uh and and that's a
microcosm of what you
are being subject to where everything in
american life now revolves around
uh what's good for the almighty dollar
and the almighty dollar looks at your
company and says hmm i can like bolt you
on you've got a lot of interesting small
business clients
i can come in and like i could cut a lot
of calls pretty quick
because dan sure is being nice to his
employees there uh and you know you're a
young man in your prime like imagine if
i made you like a 76 year old you know
and like your
kids didn't want to inherit the business
so so that's what's happening in
businesses and industries across the
board
in so many ways the reason why i spent
seven years running this
entrepreneurship non-profit is i saw the
numbers around declining
entrepreneurship around the country and
i thought that's a disaster
and it was a disaster in terms of jobs
and opportunities
and the economy but it was also disaster
socially or culturally
because i had been formed myself like
you as the
head of this small business and you
you're allowed to be a human being as a
head of a small business you know you're
allowed to do things that are frankly
not
economically optimal um just because you
feel like it
because you're you know you like that
person in your case you were like guess
what i'm going to pay you all 70k
it's like what i could have hired you
for 40k who cares i'm gonna pay you 70k
because i think it's the right thing to
do
and i think writ large um you know will
benefit from it but also
i just feel like it and i
yeah and there's like this market logic
that over uh overrides everything
if you're part of a very large
corporation where you're not allowed to
do anything that's
um economically irrational and thus
human
yeah well and and the problem with that
is it's creating a level of conformity
where everyone's doing the same thing i
mean
if you look at a lot of the decisions
that i've made made and continue to make
their decisions that i learned through
all these various like ceo learning
organizations peer-to-peer learning
organizations and just a lot of business
books
you know everything out there is like
there's only one way to do things
i mean a pretty recent example is like
when the pandemic hit we lost 55 percent
of our revenue because our 20 000 small
business clients
lost 55 percent of their revenue and our
revenue turns out is an exact function
of theirs
yep and so basically you know what we're
taught
and what you were taught i'm sure as
well in a lot of these same circles
is you want to do a very hard cut
layoff early so that you can have a
recovery story you want to cut deeper
than you need to
and then the next day you're you're back
on the front foot you're back to hiring
you're back to growth
and you protect your balance sheet
you're willing to sacrifice the people
that got you
here to protect your balance sheet and
then turn around and
potentially bring new people on board or
or save the company or whatnot and so
we're just taught in situations like
this and you see it all over with
hertz and jcpenney and you know i did
like a twitter thread even of like
bankrupt companies that are doing all
these layoffs giving huge bonuses to the
ceos
or big companies like one of my
competitors toast
they just raised 300 million dollars on
a multi-billion dollar valuation
and right afterwards they laid off 50 of
their team right after doing that
and so we're just kind of taught that
this is the only way of doing it
and it's hard but i think when people
make different decisions like we did we
said we're not going to lay anybody off
we're going to find a way to get through
this together
there's actually a lot more benefit
there than people realize it's more
viable
and i think we're proving that every day
but yet
kind of the orthodoxy if you just go
around talking to people at cocktail
parties
or reading the books or whatnot we're
just told there's only one way to do it
and it's clearly wrong so it kind of
begs the question
why are we being told that
here at yang speaks you know we're big
fans of the fact that your data should
be yours i'm i'm right now championing a
california
proposition prop 24 to help make sure
that
we can actually fight for our data and
privacy rights
one way you can make sure your data
stays private is by using
a virtual private network and the vpn we
recommend
here at yangspeaks is expressvpn it's
the number one rated vpn
by wired and cnet and one
bonus about using this thing is that you
can actually change your online location
so you can control
where sites think you are and then you
can watch
content that's only available someplace
else so that's right if you want to
be getting netflix from the uk
or japan for anime or anything that's
available in some other part of the
country
you can do it and keep your data safe by
using expressvpn
i know it's pretty wild it's essentially
like planning a flag where the internet
thinks you are
and then no one's the wiser as to what
you're seeing
or doing go to expressvpn.com
yang to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
expressvpn.com yang so
rick and morty is on the french netflix
and the fresh prince of bel air is on
the australian netflix so i've been
having a blast
with this check it out it's kind of cool
stream shows that you don't normally get
a bit of a hack here so
expressvpn.comgang get your extra
three months
[Applause]
well what i would describe uh your
approach as is
old school like you can imagine an old
school head of a business
in the 1977 or even 80s making the
decision
you're making but then the logic of
shareholder
return and capital optimization
started running the joint somewhere in
the 80s and 90s
over the last 30 years so now you're
right that like that there
are certain certain orthodox moves that
you're meant to make that the stock
market will then reward
um previously you might have just said
look
i care about my people i don't
particularly feel like firing people
i think we can get through this and that
people will appreciate the fact that we
stood up for them when
times were tough so i'd i'd love for you
to to go
a little bit further back when you first
decided to
elevate everyone's salary to 70 000
which
gained you national fame and accolades
and then some
rock throwing from rush limbaugh your
old teacher
saying i hope this company crashes and
burns just to show that
there's like like no socialist success
in the blah
you know i said i don't that's my
russian about imitation i don't know
um so you can go back and you took a pay
cut personally
in order to make this seventy thousand
dollar
uh minimum sell or you know like
salary floor possible yeah well i had
been indoctrinated in all the things
that you're saying
that we've both been talking about in
terms of kind of the system and how
other
companies think about things the
supremacy of shareholders all those
things
but it was going against what i was
actually seeing with my own eyes
and so in 2011 i was really inspired by
an employee who was telling me
she wasn't making enough and she had to
take a second job at mcdonald's to
afford to be able to work at my company
and i'm yeah and i'm like you're like
you're one of our best employees like if
you can't afford to live your life
what does that say about me and so in
2011
at the end of the year we set a goal to
average 15
raises in 2012. and then
that we thought would decrease the
profit we were
looking to rebalance the pie and make it
more fair because that's what we thought
would happen based on
everything that's said out there but our
profit actually went up
so we decided well we'll do it one more
time only in 2013.
and we did it again we exceeded the goal
our profit went up so that was happening
every year and we thought this is the
way to run a business
and in 2015 we did a survey across our
whole company
and people were generally pretty pleased
with how we were structured
but i went on a hike with my friend
valerie who is an army for 11 years
and she's such a hard worker and such an
amazing person
and she was explaining to me how a 200
rent increase was throwing her entire
life
upside down and i was like that doesn't
make any sense you're one of the best
people i know
like how is this possible that you're
not being compensated fairly
and then i learned something very
inconvenient which was a third of my
employees were making less than what
valerie was making at that time
she was making about 40k and our lowest
employees were like 30 or 35.
and it was just it was just
heartbreaking for me
and i've seen like the daniel kahneman
angus eton study about how like
you know wellness increases with income
until it doesn't and i'd read all these
things but
ironically and i'm not proud of this it
took
almost like emotional pers personal
experience where this person that i
genuinely like love and care about and
respect so much
was not being taken care of by our
economy
where i realized i was i had built a
company where i can make decisions
and yet i was just following what
everyone else was doing what was hurting
her
rather than doing what i think any
five-year-old would know would be the
right thing in that situation
well way to channel your inner
five-year-old dan because you then
became a national
hero in some circles my circles uh when
you said you know what we're gonna make
sure that everyone who works
for this company gets paid seventy
thousand dollars minimum
which happens to track with about the
income level
where money no longer affects happiness
because you would now have enough to
meet your
everyday needs yeah and i i would also
say that like
i i appreciate you saying that i think i
think ideally
we would have a world where i don't get
so much credit for doing this
and i i think i get way too much credit
and it was shocking to me
you know somebody that grew up in idaho
and like getting on the local idaho news
would be like being a celebrity in my
world like let alone like the new york
times and all these other places
um talking to you and i it it caused me
to reflect and be like why is this
happening and i don't think it's
happening
because i'm such a great person i think
it's just more
because everyone else is so [ __ ]
shitty
it's an indictment on the system it i
mean it it is
it is funny but it it's true it's an
indictment on the system that somebody
that just does something very logical
like says hey all of us built this
together shouldn't all of us
at least be able enough to live like a
normal life
that that is so radical and noteworthy
um
is really shocking to me and i think uh
we should be
somewhat ashamed as a society that
that's where we're at right now
there are certain organizations where i
i completely
think they could have done what you've
done like a while ago so
some of these organizations that are now
incredibly
wealthy and valuable and oftentimes the
leader
ends up hoovering up the lion's share of
that value in these situations
uh i can relate to a lot of your story
dan and that
but this is one thing i will suggest is
that
your business it was in a situation
where if you invested more in your
people
then it spurred more growth better opera
like better morale better retention
uh more creativity i ran an organization
that was in a similar boat where if
you're a growth company and you invest
in your people
then you end up growing more it's like
this magical relationship
and and i'm proud to say that
no i uh was following some of your
playbook during that time where
i would pay people uh more
like there was always like a level where
you kind of sensed because you know
you're the ceo of a small business like
you kind of get it
it's like i know i can get you for this
much
but i don't i'm going to pay you a
little more than that because i think
you're going to be
just happier like better more productive
less stressed out more content like i i
also was always like whatever i think i
can get them for like i'm going to like
go a little bit above that
and it's good for us right if we're like
engaging with them and they're a little
happier a little less stressed out then
we're happier and less stressed out
that's true i i wired the same way you
are which is like i want the people
around me to be happy
you don't want them not to be stressed
out about a 200
rent increase like you know like i think
that would just be better for us all
now and in my case too i did some things
where uh
and this is one of the joys of being a
small business owner where i was like
you know what like we should all go to
the beach i'm gonna rent a house
but it's got to be a big house to
accommodate everybody and then be like
everyone little bus
bus to the beach or i want to take
everyone skiing or whatever the heck it
was
those were the days i mean i um still
miss them
like my now wife uh and i were
dating during this time and she also was
like oh i missed those days because
you're like the head of this and uh you
know you're positive you want to look
out for people
i will say i'm sympathetic to folks who
run
certain types of operations in other
industries where
frankly like that relationship might not
apply
where if like you invest more and your
people like
maybe you're in like a no growth
environment
that you're like kind of managing now
that that's i think most businesses are
in situations where
they would benefit from treating people
better higher morale like higher
contentment
lower turnover like the vast majority of
businesses i believe fall on this camp
uh and i'm i'm happy to say that uh
i think that you and i had similar kinds
of experiences
as the heads of small companies i'll say
though
in our industry if you look at our
competitors
they have uh done massive numbers of
layoffs
they've increased the fees that they
charge to small businesses in opaque
ways that those businesses
can't understand or can't see right away
so they can't be held accountable
very quickly and then there are some
companies that are doing a lot of great
innovation but those companies are
telling their shareholders
that they're gonna turn around and flip
the switch at some point
and start to charge those customers a
lot more or like start to figure out how
to control costs in the ways that you're
describing
and i feel like i did get kind of
something wrong in terms of my
expectations over the past six years
and that is i thought you know with all
the hubbub and how
you know kind of how much attention we
were getting if we came out and proved
that this could work
that we would have a lot of people
following suit and we have had you know
dozens of companies follow suit and
maybe some some others in big waves but
like generally the problem's gotten
worse
and just if i can get up on my soapbox
for two minutes and highlight some of
the success we've had
i mean we've tripled as a company in the
past five and a half years
we have 10x the number of babies being
born at the company
per year like we've had 50 or 60 babies
born i love how you have that as a
measurement it's like people are
feeling reproductive we have 10x the
number of first-time homeowners
uh 70 of the people the company have
gotten out of debt 30
say they've gotten completely out of
debt but 70 percent have paid down debt
and people have between doubled and
tripled their savings for retirement
and i i think there's real implications
here for ubi
because the raise that they got is about
the same raise that a thousand dollars
times two adults in a home would get and
most of the people that work at gravity
there are they are two adult homes so i
think there's implications there
so i thought you know we prove all of
that and you would see this general
macroeconomic trend of people thinking
in this direction
but i think we've actually proven the
opposite and i think just the fact that
the story's still big i think we've
proven that people
aren't going to do it voluntarily more
than anything else because we've shown
it can work
we've shown we're like you know we're
still we're still here like we're i'm
not poor
like i'm out surfing and playing music
and you seem very happy and healthy dan
yeah have a great life and yet still
nobody's doing it and so
it's really actually emboldened my
perspective on what you're doing
because i've realized i'm not the answer
i mean maybe i'm the answer in that i
can be a part of the story and
encouraging people
and sharing what i've learned sharing
what i know but we need to all come
together
behind these types of systemic solutions
and we can't keep glorifying
individual one-offs like me freaking man
i want to give you a hug
i would love a yang hug right now this
guy gives the best hugs for everybody
else wow that's so kind of you
you do uh because what you just said is
so important
where there there was like a period and
i spent uh
you know seven years or so trying to
make something
positive happen with venture for
american entrepreneurship and i thought
something similar was like if i could
just show people
that helping these small businesses grow
is just a better path
than heading to the you know
billion dollar bank or the you know
consulting company or whatever the heck
then we could really start to fix things
and incredibly proud of everything that
venture of america continues to do
but i started realizing that the
black hole's gravity field at this point
is way way too strong
and that the software of
our economy that so many people have
internalized that you know we're all
economic inputs and that if you're a
company you have to try and like get it
down to the very last
like you know penny what you can get
away with that as soon as you can
and as soon as you can throw someone
overboard you definitely should throw
them over but like all of these things
are so deeply entrenched uh not
just in the operations of these
companies
but in our society in people's minds
that i realized that we actually need to
rewrite the rules of the economy
both from the ground up and the top down
simultaneously but the top down
component
required control of the government and
then i was like well how do you get
control of the government and then it's
like
run for president and win and have the
movement the revolution was like
and and that most people watching this
know
would have been a highly irrational
ambition circa 2018
when you know andrew yang was an
anonymous entrepreneur
but it's born of the same kind of arc
that you went through dan because
you think okay if i can demonstrate this
works then everyone will be like well it
works let's all treat our people better
and then when you're like huh people
really won't treat
like their employees better unless they
get dragged to it kicking and screaming
and the only way to drag them to a
kicking and screaming would be to to
actually get a hold of government and
change some rules
well and i think the other complicating
factor that we all need to learn
together
is how does that process of change
actually happen because i think we get
this wrong
i think that there's a certain segment
of the population right now that thinks
like demonizing joe biden or donald
trump
will make that change happen but we've
had plenty of politicians do
really shitty things that were worthy of
demonization many times
in the past and that didn't really fix
it and i think if anything we need to
try to find a way to rise above those
things and really talk to each other so
you know for me being from rural idaho a
lot of the people that i grew up with
are our trump maga people or their
libertarians or they're people that are
kind of predisposed to not necessarily
uh
want to join some of these solutions
like what you're talking about
and what i'm finding is when i actually
just see them as a human being that's
flawed the way i am that's learning the
way i am
and have a conversation and don't try to
kind of like extricate them from my life
because our beliefs don't line up or the
way we vote doesn't line up
and i just listen to them we actually
can influence each other and come
together
and i think you know we need to be
careful because right now the
the predominant way of persuasion is
kind of by like shaming and bullying
each other
and i don't know if that's going to get
people into the fold of something like
this
i'm pretty sure it's not dan and as
you've
shown for for a long time and we're all
seeing
in real time unfortunately right now
like we need these changes these changes
are not really optional if we want to
protect our way of life
which means using a sub-optimal form of
connection persuasion influence whatever
you want to call it
i don't know that we can afford to do
that right now and so i think a lot of
people kind of on the liberal side of
the equation
you know need to soften up and engage a
little bit more and not be so kind of
like harsh and mean sometimes
or or maybe even find a different way to
uh
frame some of the changes that we're
making you know it's one reason why
uh we christened universal basically
come the freedom dividend
is because it tested better with broader
swaths of the population
i liked it yeah it was hard for me to
switch back
i liked it that much and now we're kind
of back to basic income
and i actually loved the the freedom
dividend as a branding as a way of
explaining it
well thank you dan yeah yeah no it is
kind of funny
um but i think that language
really helped that make the case to
different types of people there could be
some of your
uh old neighbors in rural idaho would be
like i'm down with a freedom dividend
it's like it's a and and what what
you're describing as like the
barriers between us and trying to make
the case of different types of people
just like you have these market
incentives around
how companies treat their workers
unfortunately there are market
incentives around politics
where political figures get rewarded
more for
ginning up like a passionate group of
people
on a particular side than they do in
reaching out and
solving problems and that's going to
destroy us but but it's baked into
the way a lot of candidates have to run
where they're much more concerned about
getting primary
primaried by someone in their district
because they're a safe seat
than they are in reaching to out to
different types of people
i mean i i've been trying to write and
encourage people lately like
hey like i get that there's a lot of
horrible things happening
but like putting some focus on the
solutions putting some focus on the
changes that we want to have happen
is really our best bet in this situation
more so than the
you know latest scandal that's going to
keep us kind of all ginned up for an
extra week or two
one of the toughest things about this
time right now is taking care of
yourself
feeling healthy it's so easy to eat
poorly
right now i don't know about the rest of
you but i am not sure i've been getting
enough vegetation
in my diet and one way you can resolve
that
quickly efficiently in a way that's
doing your body right
is to use athletic greens so you mix it
with water
it creates this all-in-one drink it's
packed with
vitamins minerals everything your body
needs
and you can sense it you drink this
stuff and then your body's like what was
that
that actually was stuff that i need that
i never get
that's actually the sense you have so if
you want
to feel like you're treating your body
well in a way that's convenient
and efficient and will work for you
very very reliably go to
athleticgreens.com
yang and claim my special offer today
which is to receive
the free wellness bundle with your first
purchase
that's up to a one year supply of
vitamin d and added value when you try
their
comprehensive daily all-in-one just do
it and you're done
you feel like you did yourself a service
all in one drink
again that's athleticgreens.comyang with
your first purchase with our discount
code they'll send you a free d3 k2
wellness bundle
which includes these basically vitamin d
drops and vitamin b12 drops that you
take they don't taste like anything but
you feel amazing like more energy just
like two drops done
athleticgreens.com yang claim this offer
it's pretty
we we literally do them ourselves it's
worth it guys check them out
well now 55 percent of americans are for
universal basic income and it's
something like 76 percent for cash
relief during the pandemic which i have
to say is going to be
uh a natural lead into universal basic
income
so so dan what's fascinating is i feel
like you and i
were kind of early on this but now many
many millions of americans have joined
us
and now the big challenges is how the
heck do we restore
the connection between people and
lawmakers where
if enough of us want something it
actually happens and
and so that's something i'm now engaged
with very directly
because i see that the mechanics of our
democracy are actually going to be
something we have to solve for and that
also includes our media our social media
it's interesting but i now think that
that's going to be
one of the foremost challenges to trying
to have something like universal basic
income pass
can you give me a little bit of the
playbook on that because that'll help me
to be out there you know
like walking the walk talking the talk
with you
sure uh so the the first big move would
be something around democracy reform
like rank choice voting so if you have
ranked choice voting then people
will uh be able to vote
uh more dynamically uh you know they
they they wouldn't feel like they were
gonna like waste their vote
uh and then you would make let's call it
uh or the either democrats or
republicans more responsive to different
types of people in their district
because instead of just having to worry
about
like someone primarily them it could be
that there are a couple of different
points of view that they have to account
for
and so if you're pro democracy then
ranked choice voting
ought to be like a a near absolute good
uh and and so and it doesn't seem
particularly partisan because it's not
it's like look we should just try and
improve our democracy so it works better
and it's more representative
and you can make very compelling
arguments to people on on either side
um that this would just be
a better form of voting so that's one
big thing that i i'm going to be pushing
and championing
because it's like a process change that
strikes people as
reasonable on both sides yeah well i'm
i'm right there with you and i
completely agree
i think also you know getting money out
of politics is just we got to figure out
a way
i know with the supreme court decision
it's just really hard but like we just
have to do it because it's going to kill
us
that's exactly the kind of change that
we need to to make so i was proposing as
you know 100 democracy dollars for every
uh citizen so that you can just give it
to your favorite
candidate and then all of a sudden we
could wash out the corporate money
so that's a massive change that we need
in the worst way i'm for term limits for
legislators because i just think it's
too easy for someone to go to dc and
then just make it all about preserving
their spot
and like climbing this ladder and the
latter unfortunately stretches up for
decades
so if if you dan let's say you were to
do something bold and run for congress
then and win and you know i i would
encourage this actually
so you have a business to run the rest
of it but uh if you were to show up
there then they'd be like oh right now
you're a low man on the totem pole go
like dial for dollars and if you play
your cards right maybe you'll
wind up on one of these awesome
committees in like eight years or
or something like that and so that that
that's not helping us solve these
problems
uh and so i think we should have term
limits so that members of congress see
it as a term of service and not like
career
then you go there you try and get
something done and you turn around now
there is a balancing act
um but to me that that's necessary
because right now we have something of a
gerundocracy
where the average member of congress i
believe is about 62 years old
um which makes them a little bit behind
the curve on technology issues among
other things but
but their their incentives aren't around
solving our problems so much as they are
staying
where they are and and that is something
that
we need to address if we're going to
make progress so that so these are some
of the systemic fixes
i'm going to be pushing for um in the
days to come
it's so needed and i guess the thing
that has me most worried just is timing
right because my business is completely
dependent on small businesses like
that's
we've dedicated our entire business i've
dedicated my entire life to just trying
to help
the little guy or gal or person that
does not identify with one of those
compete
you know and you're just getting harder
and harder brother i
i feel for you so yeah it's crushing and
we we need i mean right now we're you
know congress is in recess
and we need some type of relief for
everyday people
for small businesses like we need to do
something
and i just am like you know like we we
don't want to see this change happen
because it's going to be very hard to
undo
when so many of our small businesses are
going under
as someone who's run a small business
you know it's not like you can flip a
switch
you know like your employees all drift
off and find other opportunities like
your vendors uh you know close down the
line
like you sell the equipment or furniture
like you know you can't just be like and
i'm back in a lot of these cases
well and the small businesses make those
individual choices as you highlighted
earlier
that are more human they're more in line
with the human centric
economy that you've been championing
that i've been championing because
you know they go out there they know
those people they're not making the
they're not making the decision only
based on what they saw in their business
school class or what the spreadsheet
says
they actually know the decisions they
make how they impact real people
and so if we want to make our our
economy more efficient at
and ruthless at making all of our lives
worse
all we need to do is completely get
dominated by all these large companies
and monopolies and if we want to stop
that from happening
we basically need to sell out and do
whatever we need to to protect these
small businesses
because they really are kind of as the
bible says you know a little bit of salt
goes a long way they are the salt for
our economy for our communities
having those small businesses still be
around well
they provide the majority of jobs too i
mean
it's it's beyond
vital it's central uh you know if you
imagine a world where everyone's working
for amazon
which that world is happening i don't
know if you all can sense it i mean
if you look at the amazon employee
account like it's shooting up just as
all of retail is closing so
yeah no it's not one for one
unfortunately like it's not like for
every now worker like they're hiring an
amazon worker
they eliminate five jobs and make one
and they say they're job creators
yeah yeah and then they go around being
like hey look at look at the jobs we
created
like uh you know we've got like all this
good pr around it and we're gonna yell
at you about all the jobs we created
it's like hey
like if you look at the retail sector
you're like you know that thing used to
employ
11 million people you employ 11 million
people at amazon
like no but we we employ you know
whatever they employ like hundreds of
thousands
uh it's heartbreaking too to see the way
they put the computers in charge of the
human to amazon
that is really horrific to see and
there's you know there was that
frontline documentary about this with
amazon but basically like there the
people the computers tell them what to
do
and they want the people to act with the
same ruthless form of efficiency that
the robots and computers do
and that's really horrific and
heartbreaking to see because
it dehumanizes those people that are
working then when you don't pay a living
wage
you know it dehumanizes their home life
so they have their work life dehumanized
and their home
life dehumanized at the same time my
friends at amazon are very open they say
you know we're always just trying to
automate our own jobs away like that's
just the culture of the
org it's like an efficiency engine that
place
and um i mean that's from jeff on down
like jeff's sort of like uh like a
zealot when it comes to
you know trying to get things done as
efficiently as possible and that
filters down pretty pretty quickly
uh and the antidote really is people
going out and doing what they want to do
in their community in the form of a
small business and then treating
their employees well treating their
customers while treating themselves
um well last because in my experience
small business owners like have to look
out for themselves after they look out
for everyone else under the sun
but that's that's the our only chance
really uh like this is the giant
rebalancing i was concerned about
and now pandemic has sped us up so the
the stuff that
that that andrew yang like you know
chicken little dystopian figure
like uh you know all of a sudden it's
with us right now
um i'm with you on being very very
concerned about the timing dan
it's like like like this stuff is
mission critical and needs to get passed
yesterday uh and we don't have that much
time
i mean in my case i'm obviously pushing
for
a change in leadership uh and i hope
that
if you had let's say one party in charge
of congress and
the white house they could get massive
solutions across the the the goal line
that could hopefully help preserve a lot
of these small businesses and these jobs
and the humans who have dedicated
years decades of their their lives to
building them in many many cases
and that's the other part of it too is
that like if you dedicate decades of
your life to something and then you see
it
uh disintegrate
you know like that that's devastating it
breaks my heart when i think about it
because i've been in their shoes
uh i know what it's like to be as you do
i mean you you're
you know you're like their champion
you're like the paragon of small
business
you're like the small business of small
businesses or like the
not so small like the medium-sized
business of small business
businesses and the other thing the other
reason why you can be who you are too
and your company's leadership can look
the way it does
is because you're private because you
look up and you're like hey i can just
make the
decisions that i think are our best so
my heart breaks just like yours is
i actually though think that we need a
total change in mentality a total change
of heart and a total change of thinking
and i think you're championing it
um i think that we've convinced
ourselves that people are not good
that people are bad and capital and
corporations are good
and i think if you look at the data that
i'm seeing in the experience i have it's
exactly the opposite i mean
when we got hit by the pandemic our
employees said we don't want anyone laid
off
and we don't want any increased fees or
decreased service for our small business
clients
and they got together they asked for my
permission took some time got together
and they said we don't want anyone to
get an involuntary pay cut because
maybe somebody just had somebody else
get laid off or had schools
uh interrupted and all of a sudden
expenses went up so they said we're
gonna
we're gonna do we're gonna try to get
together and do an anonymous
voluntary complete restructuring where
people take
anonymous pay cuts and we had 98
of the company asked to take a pay cut
anonymously just through this like code
of like number this person
and then they turn around pivoted and
started working with
20 000 small businesses that trust
gravity to get them reopen
and putting all these solutions into
place they did things like come
up with like this app where like coffee
shops can have starbucks type order head
coffee
where veterinarians can move the front
desk to the car because we've sent
a text message that opens up and they
can close out their folio
and they pivot and did all these things
and we're not going to make money for a
while and i'm okay with that but we're
going to survive we're going to be able
to keep helping these small businesses
as long as they're still around to be
helped
and i think that's an example where it
was shocking to me because when the
employees pitch that to me is how we're
going to recover
as a ceo it just went against everything
i was ever taught and everything all of
us are taught which is
we try to sell each other out we try to
hurt each other but that
is the behavior of corporations and if
we can actually
empower people and and in some ways
disempower
corporations or at least spread out the
power a little bit
we're gonna see more and more that and i
think because the corporations
are so bad people come across as bad if
you deal with like a com
cast customer service rep they seem like
a genuinely bad person the reality is
that person would do a fantastic job
they're a really good person
if they weren't being so mistreated by
the system and by their
employer and so i think that the the
cause for optimism that i have is
we actually don't need to change people
we just need to change the system and
the structure
around people take away what's
constraining them and then
people and then people will actually
save us but we have to actually
do it and that's the hard part yeah we
have to overrun
uh like the corporate system to give
people a chance to bring out the best in
ourselves
um and i 100 agree with you that
people if you believe in them uh like
they
expand it's well like you believed in
your people
and then they believed in themselves and
then when
dark times come they look around and say
okay we can do something about this
like you know i'm not going to wait for
like the boss to come and tell us what's
up it's like you know like i care about
you i care about
myself like you know let's try and solve
for this
um but a lot of it was because you
created that environment and you
believed in them
you know the reverse is true too that if
you're part of an organization where
they treat you like [ __ ] all the time
you know it did like dark times come
that you'll be like oh no like
like one i know they're gonna get rid of
me if they can and two like maybe i'll
like throw my colleague under the bus
because it's gonna be like me or them
and like you know like that
like the and most americans
unfortunately are laboring under like
the latter
type of situation or environment because
of the corporate logic you're talking
about
it's like if you had enough human
leaders like yourself
creating cultures where people believed
in each other
and ourselves and cared about each other
then you could solve these problems and
and my goal is to do what you've done at
gravity
uh for us all politically uh and to
reach out and say look
like these folks who are trying to turn
us against each other like just ignore
them like the fact is we know how to
solve our problems like
you get it i get it we're pretty much
like the the same with the same
motivations like
let's just come together and get this
thing done um and hopefully that message
first it's needed but hopefully that
message uh is so loud and powerful that
we can
override like you know the the software
but you know and and in your case the
in my case it was like you know it's
like the political software and the
media software and the rest of it that
we have to try and override
yeah and the interests you know in dc
and the rest of it
uh in economy-wide though
it's true that corporations the the
logic of corporations will grind us to
dust
it will end up turning us into just like
these these cogs in the machine and the
machine will eventually discard us
well and i think that's why it's so
important to get messages
out there like i worked so hard trying
to get this story out there
and people are like why do you do it
it's like well if these stories can get
out people can see
like people ask me all the time how do
you motivate your team i'm like i don't
try to motivate them i try to not
demotivate them like i'm the bad guy in
this equation they're actually do
they they will do great job just on
their own and most people will out there
and so if we can take away that and
invest instead in people's
capability and give them actual license
and power
and but i feel like what we have to do
is connect the dots between what you see
happening at gravity the story i'm out
there sharing
and what you're saying because we can
look at these as experiments when we do
what you're proposing
in small settings companies flourish
or at a very minimum they still do okay
like i'm still here i'm still happy i'm
still doing fine
and it's not like the entire the lie
we've been told is that the entire
economy and all of our jobs will go away
if we hold big companies accountable if
we put people first and
the opposite is true as a whole we will
thrive now will some people be less
wealthy
absolutely and that's fine because when
jeff bezos comes out and says
he has to start a space company because
he has so much money
it's the only thing where he can
possibly spend even a tiny percentage of
his money that he cares about
that's a signal of like hey actually he
could take that same amount of money
and he could pay 250 000 people that
work in his warehouse as a living wage
those people could then invest in their
skills and they could get better
opportunities not be held back
and those shifts if we can find a way to
harness
some of these stories and some of the
data that we're seeing
i think the proof is already there i
just think we have to get the word out
and then we'll be able to fix this
2020 is unfortunately a total disaster
for small businesses
uh you have to do anything you can
to survive and one way that you can help
your small business
is to make sure you can efficiently
onboard folks when you need them quickly
indeed.com is the number one job site in
the world because
it gets you the people and the hires you
need
fast and if you're looking for a job you
go to indeed.com
and it has the employers who are looking
actively
right now for folks like you a lot of
these types of two-sided clearinghouses
benefit from volume
and indeed is the volume business they
have over three million businesses so if
you're looking for a job
uh they're the place to go and because
of that if you're looking to hire
people they're the place to go too they
have
over 70 percent of online job seekers
and over 3 million businesses
so you know the dynamics of these
clearinghouses is that
when you get to a certain size it just
becomes more efficient and that's what
indeed has become
right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75 credit to boost your
job post
which means more people will see it
quickly try indeed out with this free 75
credit at indeed.com yang this is the
best offer
available anywhere indeed dot com yang
terms and conditions apply
offer valid just through the month of
september
[Applause]
well you are uh walking the walk as well
as talking the talk and now that you've
walked the walk you're trying to tell
people about what a great path it is
uh really congratulations to you for
being such a tremendous
person role model ceo business leader
non-conformist messenger
and champion for humanity like you know
it is a beautiful thing when you believe
in people and then they
uh prove you right and then they end up
inspiring you and then they
inspire you to do more and do better
i've had that
that experience now multiple times my
campaign was the latest where
you know like that that might have gone
quite poorly
but it said it became like this
beautiful
movement of millions of people who just
believe in
humanity and see that if we actually
invest in ourselves like we'll we'll
um do incredible things instead of like
i mean what's the opposite perspective
is like oh if you give people this money
they'll just like sit around and like
you know
like smoke and drink or do something
really negative and it's like
that's what the rich people do actually
[Laughter]
yeah it's like oh poor people just like
squander it it's like
i think poor people are a little more
careful with their money than you are
well you proved that wrong with your
campaign i saw the way you empowered
carly and zach and so many people to go
out there and they made good decisions
they represented you well they did a
great job
and i think we've proven it wrong but i
will say andrew that because of you and
because your campaign
i am a better person my life is better
and so i just want to do everything i
can to support you help get your message
out because
you know it's not like we're like fixed
kind of individuals we're open to
influence we're open to change
and the more that uh people that are in
the business world can kind of see what
you're saying
the better the world's gonna be well
you'll be
right there alongside me making the case
dan and we're gonna fight it out and we
have no choice
but to fight it out and win for
humanity's sake
uh so thank you for being uh
like a figurative rock star let's put it
that way
and i gotta say you look the part you
like does the dad look the part
if dad just came out it is like like
stan price
like rock star i'd be like yeah i
believe that
but instead you're a figurative rock
star like helping light the path
um well your rock started me andrew oh
thank you brother i really appreciate it
uh and the fact that i've uplifted you
in any way makes me really happy because
i've been inspired by you
uh and your story is awesome and more
people definitely
need to dig into what dan has done
so aside from the incredible like
journalistic accounts
like is there any someplace else that
people can can go to learn more about
funny you should ask that we didn't plan
this but i wrote this book
about it it's called worth it and i kind
of chronicled like some of those
highlights that i shared and a lot of
other surprising things
i think basically it's an account of how
most of what we're telling ourselves
about the business world and what's
possible
is wrong but it's just kind of my
journey
because i don't feel like at 36 i'm wise
enough to really preach at people yet
and so it's just my journey of of kind
of
turning over rocks and discovering that
kind of one step at a time
the the publishing industry you know
they offered to
do a really you know big deal with it
but they wanted me to simplify it down
to like do this like do this one thing
seven steps to a magical business by dan
price
i just self-published it because i
actually just wanted to be honest with
people about
yeah maybe some places where i got it
right but more importantly where i got
it wrong
and where there's opportunity for growth
and change so yeah i've worked really
hard on this book called worth it and
it's doing really well for an
independent book
well worth it by dan price and people
learn most from stories
anyway like you know instead of some
some bulleted list
um so yes like there's a lot i'm sure
there's a
there are a ton of people that are gonna
snap up worth it and uh hopefully
dig into your story and learn from it
but but buy it from a local bookstore
a physical local bookstore don't buy it
from amazon i'm trying to get everybody
to not buy it from amazon you might have
to wait an extra week or two but you can
read another book in the meantime
you heard it here first don't get this
thing in amazon
[Laughter]
thanks so much dan congratulations on
everything man thanks andrew it feels
really nice to talk to you and reconnect
you know so uh and i i hope you don't
take this in like the you know it's like
i knew that we were going to have this
conversation you know in the sense of
like
like i was like of course dad's going to
be on young speaks and because
so it was so obvious i like uh you know
i was like
let me try and do some other like i love
that
but but you should know like that this
was to me like
you know like a 100 percent um
like an inevitability yeah well i feel
like we
like uh share something that i can't
even put words to and it really means a
lot to me to
to meet somebody like you and to just
feel like um
a little bit of uh honestly like a
feeling of being at home
it's really nice well it's
it's like this uh it's it's this
opportunity to be human that both you
and i have had you know it's like where
you're in uh
you're in a role where it turns out your
being more human
ends up um being very positive uh
you know and and now i'm in the same
boat where like you know i'm like a
movement leader so my being like a
a human being is actually also very good
for the movement um
and you look around you see these other
people or put in environments or it's
like huh like
you get rewarded for being a total
[ __ ] oh my god
an automaton and like doing like really
mean things
interesting and like you know so we're
looking around being like
the ranks of humanity are shrinking and
like the ranks of like miserable
uh [ __ ] is growing um and and so you
and i are like
we gotta spread the antidote before like
the freaking [ __ ] contagion gets
everybody
yeah well and you know we actually do
the things that capitalists claim to
kind of glorify we take risks we do
things the hard way
we don't necessarily take the easy way
out because like we're willing to
actually go for it and
yeah just throwing somebody under the
bus for a long time like that's like an
easier
way out there's so many ways like not
paying people right is an easy way out
like bowing down to investors external
investors there's so many easy ways out
and i think that the there's i think
that there's a lot of
unfortunately wimps out there who just
aren't willing to take that hard
difficult you know kind of risky path
you know at the top
and it's so inspiring to see somebody
who's like hey yeah like everything's
stacked against me
but i know what the right thing is and
so i can't let go of that
even even if my chances are one percent
or five percent or a tenth of a percent
it's still the only thing that's going
to save us and it's what we have to go
for
so amen brother that you pretty much
summarized my thinking
running for president if you look up
being like oh it's always gonna save
us like whatever my chances are i just
gotta go do it and
and other than bernie maybe uh you know
i think you've had the most
influence on polling actual the the
people
of any candidate including donald trump
and joe biden
of actually changing the culture and
changing how people are thinking
like you and bernie were the two people
i think that we're doing that and so
that's inspiring to think about and
hopefully people that are more kind of
like in i don't want to name any names
but people that kind of put their finger
up in the wind
hopefully you've actually changed the
direction of that wind so when they put
their finger up
they're going to come up with a
different answer than they would have
had you not run
thank you man we're trying and one of
the things too like you it's like
you know you have to operationalize it
so in our case it's like
trying to help elevate certain down
ballot candidates where if
the the you know wind testers are like
oh [ __ ] like
you know you go you go that direction
you win you go that direction you lose
it's like oh
i should go in the winning direction so
like when i'm i'm trying to grind to
make the right direction the winning
direction
uh and we've got a real shot at it i
mean there are some candidates who've
won their primaries and i think may end
up in congress
that are aligned with you and me um so
it's been fun on that level
uh and that there is like uh you know a
band of humans still fighting for the
future
um and i'm happy to say that they are
like you
like some of my favorite people so
it's got that going for it too it's like
you get really awesome people together
it's a fun party to be a part of like
the the
i mean i still sometimes long for the
days of the
active yang presidential campaign but
even you know the movement that you've
continued to carry forward
and you know how it connects to what i'm
doing and a lot of other people out
there
it's just a wonderful group to be a part
of it's a it's just a pleasure
and i think that's one thing that maybe
also could help us
is like it's actually pretty nice to be
in a place where people have their needs
met
where they're taken care of where like
they care about each other
they care about like the whole and
they're not just out for it for
themselves like that's a really
wonderful place to be and being in the
opposite place
like kind of soul sucking so yeah
yeah i think we can continue to grow
during this time just in a different way
you're right
it's a little bit less like let's do it
i like that one though
i'm not gonna lie your campaign was the
most fun campaign that i've ever
seen in my life by a long shot so right
and and
you know i do miss it and i did it like
you know there will be a time when i'm
sure we get back to
so you know like the the that version um
i
like i'm still fighting in my own way
you know it's like a little bit less uh
um strident i guess but uh you know and
like a
few more like genuflections to
[Laughter]
to like joe and cabala but yeah it's all
good
you're doing great i love that video you
made by the way with the other primary
candidates
uh for the dnc i caught that on youtube
and i thought it was really well done
yeah you know what was funny is some of
the production team behind the dnc was
yang gang they actually said it to me
when they were filming they're like hey
fyi like i was like
i'm yang gang and i was like oh that's
cool and then
they like got a good clip of me in there
i'm like nice work
production
is your family doing all right
everything going okay with home friends
yeah yeah they're they're all right
they're good things are good here man um
you know like
a lot of it it's true this is actually
the microcosm of the world we're in
right now
like as long as like daddy's good and
like my spirit is good then like
you know because i reflect on it so when
i think about how my family's doing
most of it has something to do with how
i'm doing yeah
you know because like if i'm good and i
i'm
not to say like daddy's and i'll be all
the family because i'm not but it's just
like my
my sense of how the family is doing is
like very much uh dependent upon my own
state of mind
yeah i mean i i love that you know thing
that people talk about
like you put the mask on your own face
then you help other people put the mask
and i think
people get it wrong in two ways they
start putting masks on other people's
faces on the one side of the equation
but then
on the other side of the equation they
take all 200 mass and put them on theirs
and so i think you know us staying
healthy you know doing our health
routines like making sure that we're
like so
literally just physically healthy is
such a game changer in terms of how we
can help other people around us
especially for you and me because you
know like you we're both carrying a lot
of weight a lot of people
need us yeah yeah that's really cool to
see
well dan i can't wait for this
conversation to be out there uh it was a
blast
and uh yeah like let us know if there's
anything we can do to help
um sounds great but like thrilled to be
fighting this fight alongside you
thank you same here i'm i'm available
anytime you need me thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]